- So on what date do I tell
her dad that I love him?
- Um.
(upbeat music)
- Today, I'm gonna be getting
relationship advice from teenagers.
- How old are you?
- I'm 15.
- Cool, that's cool, I used to be 15.
Not horrible and awkward at all.
- How old are you guys?
- We're 14.
- Both, well, duh.
- I'm having some trouble
with my girlfriend's dad,
and I'm must wondering, how
do I get him to like me?
- Well in a modern sense,
you could find out some
of his interests without
asking beforehand.
- Okay.
- The good old internet
stalk is a good way to go.
- Sure, he's not on the internet.
- I'm in the Navy.
- That's so cool.
- Some of the challenges are that we're in
the middle of the ocean,
so there's not a lot of
internet, so it's very difficult
to communicate with your spouse.
- How much longer are you in the Navy for?
- 13 years.
- So you signed your life away?
- I know you guys said you haven't been
in a relationship before, but if you were
to be in a relationship,
are you comfortable
with your significant other
can go hang out with his ex.
- I don't know.
Like, I guess it depends on
how the relationship ended,
you know.
- Like, I guess it would all be different,
and it's a conversation you
really need to talk through.
- Teenagers say be honest.
Adults, you guys lie too much.
All right, cut it out.
- How about you get a boyfriend
who works on like a cargo ship?
- Ooh, another ship boyfriend.
- Or you could just have a swimmer
who just likes swims next to the boat.
- If there's any swimmers out there.
- So you're gonna be 39 when
you get out of the Navy?
That's like too old to get married.
- I guess what I'm wondering is,
when do I call him Dad?
- You should probably ask your girlfriend
when that would be
appropriate and comfortable
for everybody involved.
- Do I call him Dad, or
should I call him Pop-Pop?
Dr. Dad, Mr. Dad?
That sounds pretty formal, Sir Dad.
Call him Da-Da, kinda like make him like
think that I'm this baby again,
bring him back to the
good old days, Da-Da.
That actually sounds like a
wonderful and perfect idea.
- Great, we're making great progress here.
- If you meet a person
that you really like
and you're putting your career first,
above the relationship, if the person,
you guys will make it work if you guys
are meant to work together.
- Maybe it isn't the right person
if you're putting your career before them.
- Baby.
- Like what emojis can I send him?
- I would go straight in with
all of the colored hearts.
- Even the black heart?
Show I got a bad boy edge.
- Yeah.
- You need a very rich boyfriend.
- I do need a very rich boyfriend.
Rich boyfriends.
- Can I be like, what's up,
Dad, nail painting emoji?
- Yeah.
- Kind of a little foreshadowing
of something we might do
down the line, me and the dad.
Then we'll have a nice dinner.
I'll ask him if I can call him Da-Da.
And uh.
- Present him with the New Balance shoes.
- Give him those grass-stained
New Balance sneakers
that he's always wanted.
- I thank you so much for the advice.
It was really good advice.
- I know.
(laughing)
- Yeah, we'll submit our invoice later.
- I believe that relationships
can be successful
if you operate by these four things.
Communication, honesty,
understanding and respect.
- Rich boyfriends, call her.
(upbeat music)